Speaker 1: All right. I want to talk just
a little bit more about Charlie Kirk,
but this is really not about Charlie Kirk.
This is actually about the trans kids issue
and a new version of the same tired, homophobic
talking point from 15 years ago or even longer.
Let's start with a clip to tell you what I'm
talking about. Here is Charlie Kirk saying
that tick tock is turning kids, transgender,
turning kids transgender. The language really
matters here. Listen to what he has to say.
Speaker 2: I want to play a piece of tape here,
Jack, and get your reaction. This is
Senator Tom Cotton talking about how,
hey, if you're fired up about the balloon, wait
till I tell you about tick tock play. Cut to.
Speaker 4: Well, China has been waging a Cold
War against the United States for decades,
and unfortunately, not many of our leaders
have acknowledged that. They want to deny that
it's happening. But when a nation like
China is waging a Cold War against us,
the only choice is whether to
win or to lose. I think this
spy balloon that so vividly went across America
is a very high profile reminder to Americans
about what the Chinese communists have been
up to, because I got to tell your viewers,
if they're worried about a spy balloon flying
across Middle America, let me tell them about the
tech talk app that they may have on their phone
and what it means for their security and their
privacy and that of their children as well.
Speaker 2: Yeah, And not to mention Tik Tok
is turning kids trends. Jack,
we're already in a Cold War.
Speaker 1: The the degree the casual nature with
which these people say insane things. Yeah. And
by the way, Tik Tok is turning kids trends now.
Couple different things here that I think are
important to point out. First and foremost, the
Charlie Kirk show is on Tick Tock. Okay? He has
not as many followers as we do. Fine, but over
200,000 followers on TikTok, The Charlie Kirk
Show. If Charlie Kirk thinks that Tik Tok is a
problem, then why is Charlie Kirk on Tick Tock?
Making the problem worse by directing viewers of
his onto that platform? But I want to talk about
this idea of turning kids trans. This is verbatim
what used to be said about kids being turned gay.
15 years ago on this show, I went in, I
would interview virulent homophobes like
Peter LaBarbera and Chaplain Gordon CLINGAN
Schmidt and the Westboro Baptist Church people
and Dr. Paul Cameron. Is he still alive, by the
way? I'm actually curious about that. Dr. Paul
Cameron Let's see. Apparently he is. Yeah, he's
83 years old. So I would interview these folks
and remember at the time they Bryan Fisher was
another one. They never really were too worried
about lesbians. Gay men was their focus. And one
of the things they would say is kids are being
convinced. Boys in particular are being convinced
to be gay. Now they've switched to kids are being
convinced to be trans. You can't convince
people to be gay or trans. Now, I want to do
this thoroughly because I think that this entire
talking point is B.S. and it's dangerous. But
there is one conversation that we can have about
this. Okay? You really can't convince people to
be gay or trans if that you know, if it's seven or
something. You had started to say, hey, don't you
find these little boys attractive, David? Or it's
great, too, Like boys instead of girls, whatever,
right? There's no way that you can convince
people to be gay or trans. What can happen
is that people who are gay or trans might not
be comfortable expressing that because of social
stigma or pressure or fears or whatever, and that
if they perceive that it would be fine for them to
just be who they are, they don't have to hide it.
You might see more young people willing to express
who they actually are. That is absolutely true
that when you reduce stigma and you reduce fear,
people are just more comfortable telling you
who they are. Now, all of that being said.
I am open to the idea that the discourse can
temporarily encourage people to see solutions to
a problem they're having in whatever is prevalent
in the narrative. And what I mean by that is there
are. Now, here, I'm not talking about people who
are trans. What I am talking about is there are
people who, for all sorts of different reasons
in their lives, come to have what we might call
a crisis. They aren't happy with their lives or
with who they are or with how things are going
or whatever the case may be. I know people who
become fixated in an unhealthy way, for example,
on a particular diet. I am aware of someone
who was having problems in their life and
they decided it was diet related. They believed
their food was making them depressed and all of
these different things. And so they said, I'm
only going to eat fruit and nuts. And they
did that for a year and it was completely
extreme and terrible. And then they said,
you know, the problem is my diet, but it's
the wrong diet. I'm going to go on the
meat diet, essentially. And they were eating, you
know, sticks of butter and ten eggs for breakfast
or whatever. And then they realized I just what
I really needed was actually just to sort out
emotional problems I was having. I should just
be eating a normal diet. I am open, although I
have not seen evidence that this is going on. I
am open to the idea that for kids of a certain
age where there are these sort of struggles and
identity issues that they might temporarily,
if what they are hearing about is being trans,
they might wonder, maybe that's the issue that
I'm having. And then, of course, at some point
they would realize that that it is actually not
that I am open to all of this other stuff. You can
convince kids to be trans that there's no evidence
of it whatsoever. And it's quite frankly absurd
that Charlie Kirk just so offhandedly says it